campanas que resuenan en bolivia con
orgullo la fiesta grande de tarija en
honor a san roque fue declarada
patrimonio inmaterial de la humanidad
por parte de la unesco la celebración de
origen religioso data de la época de la
colonia española cuando los habitantes
de la ciudad pedían al santo que les
protegiera de enfermedades
[Música]
[Risas]
en la que realmente
te encuentras con
[Música]
la divinidad
la unesco también incorpora a esta lista
el ciclo festivo alrededor de la
veneración y culto de san juan bautista
en venezuela
es increíble
barlovento en lo que vivimos lo que
hacemos todo significa la negrita no los
afrodescendientes
así como las danzas asociadas a la
festividad de corpus christi de panamá
para mí representa
demasiado ya que esto se trata de
santísimo sacramento
el pasillo un género musical ecuatoriano
el pasillo básicamente retrata la
historia
y la producción de cerámica del pueblo
awajún de perú